[Musique]
yes
merci beaucoup
j'avoue j'ai pas toujours 8-7 est la
petite est plutôt gros et avait les
cheveux plats tout lisse et on
m'appelait boubou le message et celui à
30 ans au mois d'ailleurs savez vous que
en 2030 65% d'entre vous exerceront un
métier qui n'existe pas encore rien de
grave je vous rassure
c'était pareil pour moi mon époque on
n'imaginait pas du tout l'impact que
l'informatique aurait sur notre
quotidien
j'avais pourtant le sentiment que moi
c'était ça le futur
alors pendant que mes potes aller eux au
tennis le mercredi je prenais des cours
d'informatique
je sentais que je mettais en place des
connexions dans mon cerveau mais comment
optimiser le code dans sa tête
une première réponse m'est apparu avec
le rubik's cube pour le résoudre
c'est plutôt simple il suffit de prendre
le temps de l'observer ensuite seulement
les doigts et les mains prennent le
relais puis on recommence on observe et
les mains et les doigts prennent le
relais et on recommence on recommence en
boucle ces cycles reflète assez bien le
type des changes qui vient entre le
cerveau gauche et le cerveau droit dans
notre cerveau je me suis dit je vais
appréhender tous les systèmes de cette
manière là d'abord dans un premier temps
télécommande envisagé visualiser la
structure de base celle qui est
inamovible qu'on ne peut pas remplacer
qui soutient les couches superficielles
ensuite justement identifier quels sont
les couches superficielles qui
complètent cette structure de base et
forment l'ensemble qui est perçu par
notre cerveau et nos cinq sens
cette modulation visuel est devenu un
système de pensée qui me permet de
naviguer maintenant
deuxième déclic a eu lieu quand je me
suis mis à la guitare oui un jour je me
suis mis à la guitare les sans le savoir
j'étais déjà en train de faire une mise
à jour de mon système de pensée de
programmeurs finger aqp bunker j'étais
en train de passer à un autre modèle et
c'est celui dont j'ai envie de vous
parler maintenant
le music thinking
faites-y des professionnels cette
identité professionnelle et celle qui me
permet maintenant de naviguer
confortablement de business en business
et la chance c'est qu'elle se consolide
encore plus à chaque étape
ça n'a pas coulé de source au début j'ai
cru qu'il suffirait simplement de
reprendre le modèle que j'avais élaboré
dans la programmation ou sur le cube et
de les coller sur la guitare mais non
non non non non mais non c'est la fin
marché pas du tout c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
il me manquait une dimension je
n'arrivais pas identifié et ce n'était
pas la technique pure ni les algorithmes
qui allait me transformer en jimi
hendrix alors j'ai juste monter un
groupe avec des potes on a pris notre
pied en imaginant qu'on allait bosser
dans la cybernétique ça faisait genre à
l'époque
c'est un jour quand une copine m'a dit
mais tu rigoles c'est un super mec tu
joues la guitare que j'ai saisi cette
inconnue à mon équation
c'était la dimension affective cette
sensibilité aux émotions ne permettait
alors de déployer des interactions avec
les autres humains
en fait ça voulait dire moi ados qui
joue de la guitare je pouvais enfin
plaire aux filles avec les coudes grâce
à l'ecoute j'arrivais à comprendre ce
qui se passait et à envisager d'autres
types de relations j'ai décidé alors
d'affiner cette perception est cette
restitution des émotions ça a porté ses
fruits
j'en ai fait mon métier est depuis plus
de 20 ans c'est un de mes métier et une
passion la musique est un médium
extraordinaire pour triturer les
émotions et les sentiments en studio par
exemple j'ai appris comment composer un
tube qui est capable de se démarquer
entre deux publicités pour un lave
vaisselle d'une voiture ou encore se
démarquer sur le dancefloor imbibé entre
deux méga tube deux internationaux sur
scène aussi j'ai beaucoup appris le
métier de musicien engeance des
collaborations qui sont hissés dans des
conditions pas toujours très agréables
qui varie sans cesse entre la grande
détente
on est tous potes ont su abuse et la
haute pression du no business like you
business imaginez la piscine d'un hôtel
5 étoiles la nuit après en fait un
concert qui s'est très très très très
très très très très mal passé devant une
brochette de vip qu'il fallait
convaincre
forget ou encore 11 heures de voyage
complètement jet lag qui s'enchaînent
avec un concert devant 20000 personnes
qui chantent et qui dansent sur le son
de vos doigts qui eux sont encore
engourdis pour juste après partir à
larache juste après les dédicaces aller
voir des baleines
à l'autre bout du monde avec dans le
ventre juste une poutine pour vous tenir
l'estomac
ça laisse des traces
travailler dans cet environnement n'a
permis quand même de faire évoluer mon
système
ma visualisation des systèmes dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure en fait
c'est comme une chanson vous avez le
texte qui se tient sur la mélodie
qui elle même est retenu soutenue par
une série d'accords qui défilent dans le
temps et ces derniers sont
fondamentalement posée sur des basses
en bougeant en triturant en distorsion
un de ses éléments dans le temps je
génère de l'émotion et cela appelle du
sentiment c'est formidable c'est ainsi
que ces dizaines de milliers d'heures
passées à cocquerez des chansons pop des
arrangements des orchestrations
sophistiqués des spectacles un peu
glamour sont maintenant devenus de la
valeur dans les secteurs de la finance
dans l'industrie du meuble ou même tout
simplement en famille ou son ventre le
borgne
le music thinking c'est ce que j'utilise
aujourd'hui dans un tiers de l'activité
se tient là consiste à accompagner les
entreprises dans l'innovation
c'est très à la mode en ce moment ça
ressemble à peu près à des workshops du
travail en groupe avec des gens qui
n'ont pas d'idées on les accompagne dans
la créativité à l'aide d'outils visuels
pour essayer de trouver des solutions
ces outils visuels sont issus d'un d'une
méthode qui s'appelle le design thinking
et dans ce contexte j applique donc ce
que moi j'appelle le mieux vikings ça
consiste tout simplement à
appliqués les usages et les réflexes
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
dans ces milieux dans ces milieux un peu
plus corporate ou académique
l'exemple le plus simple c'est comment
je peux coacher des gens en leur parlant
de tempo de rythme de refrains
accrocheurs
d'incarnation du propos plus bluffant
une histoire assez drôle c'est comment
j'ai réussi un jour à
gérer une crise managériale imaginez une
manne à dieuze en furie qu'a réussi à
envoyer tous les mecs du bureau à
l'autre bout de la salle j'ai posé ma
veste comme ça je me suis assis sur le
bus rouge bézy
écoute ma chérie tu es musicien sont pas
parfaits mais c'est les meilleurs du
monde
ta chanson tu la connais alors t'en fais
pas on va y arriver
devinez quoi le divorce élevé tranquille
l'air de rien alors repris là où on en
était et tout s'est bien passé
une autre fois encore j'étais sur un
plateau avec katy perry et j'avais envie
de voir les photos je prends mon boitier
jeu de fil à un mec posée au bord de la
seine et je lui dis excuse moi tu peux
vous prendre des photos pendant que je
joue et le mec me répond pas il me
regarde avec des grands yeux et je vois
bien que justement dans ses yeux il n'a
pas du tout envie de prendre en photo en
fait c'était l'artiste suivant un dj de
renom ayant reconnu dans le monde entier
mais que je ne connaissais pas ça m'a
servi depuis avant chaque réunion
je check qui sont les gens dans la salle
et surtout quel est leur statut qui
n'est jamais écrit sur leur front et en
fait ça a tout changé depuis j'y arrive
à parler à des présidents du cac 40
comme ça en one-to-one en mode rock star
et c'est plutôt pratique
j'en ai des dizaines des histoires comme
ça
mais celle dont je vais vous parler
maintenant c'est la première fois que
j'ai appliqué consciemment ce mode music
linking on m'avait demandé de faire une
présentation pour les résultats
financiers d'une filiale à son groupe
les chiffres étaient excellents et la
directrice voulais autre chose qu'un
pauvre powerpoint
voyez ce que je veux dire donc elle m'a
appelé et j'ai dégainé levée devait
lever
yes cette courbe
elle est née en fait en répétition un
jour j'étais avec un groupe de rock on
savait jouer nos morceaux dans tous les
sens alors pour s'amuser ont réajusté
les titres dance qui nous amuser et en
fonction de l'auditoire en respectant
quand même
sept principes d'énergie au début vous
avez un crochet qui sert à prendre
l'auditeur par la main et le garde avec
vous ensuite il fallait qu'on fasse
toujours attention à trouver le morceau
le plus mou le slow la balade
celui que tout le monde veut entendre
qui plombe l'ambiance donc s'arranger
pour bien le mettre au creux de la vague
là où tout le monde dort et le plus
important c'est au niveau de la boucle
vous avez l'offrande de cadeaux c'est le
morceau le titre le plus énergique celui
qui va faire danser tout le monde au
début vous remplissez aussi avec au
niveau de la bosse un tube assuré
histoire de vous mettre dans l'ambiance
et pour conclure vous avez le rappelle
c'est le morceau qui va trotter dans
toutes les têtes qu'il a donné aux gens
de revenir vous voir la prochaine fois
en business et le one more thing de
steve jobs et pour la présentation des
résultats financiers
ça s'est passé comme ça au début on a
affiché le titre accrocheur de sa
présentation
ensuite au niveau de la bosse on a fait
une annonce un peu sexy dans ce genre de
présentation s'est remplie de données de
data de soutien habitable on les met
juste derrière en direction du cru il
faut s'assurer de mettre les plus
mauvais chiffres tout en bas quand on
leur en suite pour remonter vous mettez
une petite annonce une bonne nouvelle et
en os au niveau de la boule pour tous on
est réveillé vous parlez du produit
phare celui qui a généré le plus de
bénéfices et que tout le monde connaît
pour conclure c'est assez facile vous
parler d'un truc prometteur quelque
chose qui va bien se passer vous avez
déjà gagné tout est possible cette
courbe
elles marchent vraiment pour tous je
m'en sers on pense pratiquement 2 3 fois
par semaine depuis plus de vingt ans
c'est assez extraordinaire
je m'en sers pour faire des
présentations donc écrire des livres
créer des jeux vidéo je fais tout ça oui
plein d'autres choses encore et
notamment je me suis servi pour une idée
j'ai pas bien entendu je suis servi pour
ce tadjiks regarder au début je vous ai
accroché avec le livre vous le j'avoué
bull
ensuite je vous ai parlé de vos futurs
emplois à réinventer puis j'ai enchaîné
avec des exemples les aidant les
exemples qu'il fallait un pareil et
maintenant nous sommes tout en bas vous
dormez bien relevé et maintenant je vais
vous parler de l'état de flou l'état de
flou quelqu'un le cannet c'est cet état
mental que tu atteins quand tu est
extrêmement concentré sans faire
d'effort tué à fond dans l'engagement et
plus rien ne tourne compte apparemment
ça correspond à des cycles fluide entre
le cerveau gauche et le cerveau droit
qui se situe entre 7 5 et arte et 12.5
ftf ce qu'on appelle aussi ondes alpha
cet état mental est tellement agréable
que le temps ne conclue mais non
seulement le temps mais plus rien ne
tourne comptes met d'ailleurs pourquoi
vous parlez du floor maintenant parce
que justement c'est lui de dénominateur
commun le commun entre toutes les
expériences dont je vous ai parlé tusson
tout varié
cet état mental qui est hors du temps
c'est lui qui me permet à chaque fois de
valider par exemple qu'une session de
travail collaboratives et bien comprises
cas rendez vous d'affaires est sur la
bonne voie qu'un cours de guitare est
assimilée mais un meilleur exemple pour
vous expliquer le flou si nous expliquer
comment on en sort vous regardez un film
et le mot fin apparaît sur l'écran
seriez vous me dire juste avant le mot
fin étiez vous dans le film ou dans la
vraie vie
c'est pareil à la fin d'un bon livre
quand le mot fin apparaît étiez vous
dans le livre ou dans la vraie vie
à la fin d'une bonne partie d'un jeu
vidéo étiez vous dans le jeu dans la
vraie vie c'est pareil en bas de la
piste de ski
juste avant où sommes nous sur nous dans
un état de flou en groupe en plus en
fait nous sommes là au niveau de la bvk
et c'est le moment pour conclure que je
vous parle des métiers qui reste à
inventer
parce que justement demain vous allez
avoir plusieurs métiers c'est certain
alors je vous invite dès aujourd'hui à
multiplier les opportunités a essayé
beaucoup de choses
essayez hacker modifié les usages pour
vous forger et trouver une identité
professionnelle
cela vous permettra de louvoyer d'un
business à l'autre un peu comme je le
fais maintenant
cela vous permettra aussi de partage et
de la connaissance avec d'autres
cerveaux d'autres types de cerveaux des
humains d'autres humains ou pas
d'ailleurs
des robots peut être certainement voir
des humanoïdes
pour ça essayez inventé ac et des usages
ayez des recettes améliorer la pensée
qui vous ressemble devenez votre propre
avatar professionnel en un mot créé le
hashtag qui vous ressemble créé le
hashtag de votre état d'esprit
le mien c'est music smoking quel est le
vôtre
quel est votre hashtag avoue hashtag
donc à vous dirais-je
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]